My name's Marco Calzini and I live in Durham.
My business is Adventure Valley in the Northeast of England.
We've had Bertie just over four years.
He was given to us by a lady who emigrated to a different country.
And he's been with us ever since.
Bertie loves his girlfriend Shelly.
He lives with her all the time.
And he loves to meet people, most of all.
That's what he looks forward to, and that's when he puts on a good show.
A lot of people noticed that he was very fast.
So we then started to think, "Yeah, we might have something here."
And we actually looked it up and realized, yes, he is an unusually fast tortoise.
Everybody here is so proud, especially my wife Janine and all the staff.
We're overwhelmed, and most of all, we're so proud of Bertie...
...to be a Guinness World Record holder.